[Music]
introducing the Rockstar editor a new
tool that allows players to record edit
and share videos in Grand Theft Auto 5
and Grand Theft Auto online record
gameplay footage while on or off mission
with a simple press of a button
or after an epic stunt use the action
replay feature to capture the last few
moments of gameplay the Rockstar editor
provides a robust suite of recording and
editing tools using the project timeline
you can add a range trim and string
together multiple clips add text and
your favorite tracks from the radio
stations or score to make more or less
whatever you can dream up
there's a wide array of editing options
featuring multiple camera modes camera
filters audio mix adjustments and more
for you to play with in director mode
you can stage your own scenes and create
custom moments does it hang it
select the GTA story mode character your
favorite four-legged beasts or even a
bird set the location time of day
weather patterns for gameplay
modifications like explosive punches or
low gravity when finished with a project
export videos to your video gallery
upload your final product to youtube and
the rockstar games social club to share
with friends
the Rockstar editor is a powerful tool
that allows players to share their Grand
Theft Auto 5 and grunt EFT Auto online
experiences in an entirely new way